see monsters are considered to be
mythical creatures at the center of tall
tales but science tells a story of
real-life monsters lurking in Earth's
prehistoric seas monsters called
please eeeh sores Plesiosaurus were
ancient marine reptiles that first
appeared about 215 million years ago
they belonged in the order please yo
Soria which is divided into two groups
the long-necked plesiosaurs and the
short-necked pliosaurus plesiosaurs were
massive animals they grew up 243 feet
long with large bodies and small
triangular heads with smooth sharp teeth
their most signature feature was their
long necks spanning half the length of
their body sleaziest sore necks had up
to seventy six distinct vertebrae over
ten times more than that found in humans
older depictions portray these necks as
willowy and snake light but recent
discoveries have shown that they were in
fact relatively stiff this allowed the
Plesiosaurus
to stay streamlined while swimming or
while hunting fish squid and clams
while the plesiosaur is evolved long
nets and small heads their playas or
cousins went the opposite direction
their necks were short and their heads
were large measuring up to 10 feet long
but much like plesiosaurs pliosaurus
were massive growing up to 50 feet long
and weighing almost 100,000 pounds
despite their large size
pliosaurus were excellent swimmers
capable of reaching speeds near 10 km/h
their speed along with their great size
allowed pliosaurus to become ferocious
predators devouring large marine animals
and even other plesiosaur eeeyah
despite their differences
pliosaurus and please a source has
shared a few key features that were
characteristic of the genus plesiosaur
iya
they used all four of their flippers to
swim in a form of underwater flight
similar to the movement of a dragonfly
and while they spent their entire lives
in the sea
please iya Soares had no gills rather
there were air breathers coming up to
the surface for oxygen before every dive
by about 66 million years ago these
powerful predators died out but today
they continued to be points of
fascination inspiring legends as grand
as the monsters themselves
[Music]